hi I'm Evan Carmichael and today's one
minute monday is support your team find
something you can do for somebody who's
helped you with your business just to
help them along on their journey so
quick example last week the one minute
video was with Jason he's been part of
my crew for a while and I said Jason
wanted to come over tomorrow will film a
one-minute Monday and you're gonna be on
it instead of me and it was during the
World Cup and Italy was playing that was
my home team and I thought you know what
does a half-hour break and this can come
well film or take a couple take so we've
done in 15-20 minutes and i will have a
great video he came was excited that
ended up taking over an hour and i
missed I missed most of the second half
of the game because we had to do another
take and another take and I was giving
him advice and he was soaking it all in
and to make his video better and I
didn't mind that I missed the game
because I was doing something nice you
know Jason felt great who was
appreciative of the opportunity I felt
great for helping them out my audience
you guys loved the video you're
commenting on it you're sharing it I
really appreciate that and sometimes you
need things in your business to make you
feel good about your business you know
it can be hard just getting up and going
to work every day and you can get that
when you help people out so find a way
to support somebody on your team if you
don't have a team yet just think about
the people who are in your life who've
given you even moral support for your
business find a way this week to help
them say thank you help them along their
journey it'll make you feel great it'll
make them feel great and you'll be off
to a great week believe you guys like
this video thumbs up below leave a
comment and subscribe to the channel
click on my face thank you so much I'll
see you soon